Supply chains have grown
increasingly more complex,
and they are very much global.
Think about your iPhone for example.
It's designed in California,
but components are sourced from suppliers
in 43 different countries,
across six continents.
These parts go through their
own manufacturing processes,
which involve a number
of different transactions
and interactions.
It's incredibly hard just
to understand the origin
of where raw materials are coming from.
Even in the 21st century,
large parts of today's supply chains
still rely on paper based records
and as products are shipped worldwide,
the paper trail continues to grow.
If you want to ship a container
from Mombasa to Rotterdam,
you end up with a pile of paper
that is 25 centimeters high.
So imagine how many documents and papers
are being moved around.
With paper comes inefficiencies
and digital technologies
could help overcome them.
One of them, blockchain,
is floated as a solution
that could do that
securely and efficiently.
It offers a way to trace
a product's journey
from grain to bottle or
from thread to shirt.
Brands are now starting
to realize its potential
with consumers willing to pay
a premium for transparency.
This is Walmart's second
blockchain project,
Target is also pushing into this space.
The $50 trillion supply chain industry
is moving to blockchain.
If you are drinking a cup
of coffee this morning
or tonight you're gonna
grab a bottle of beer,
there's a very good chance that there
is a smallholder farmer
in Ecuador or Zambia
that is growing that
coffee or that barley.
These are some of the
poorest people in the world,
and they're completely invisible
in the global supply chain.
Almost everything we buy
has passed through a supply chain.
These vast networks are responsible
for transforming raw
materials into products
and getting them into customer's hands.
Yet for most of us, they remain hidden.
The upstream parts of supply
chains are the most obscure
and hardest to untangle.
This is where the production begins,
usually with a person that
gathers the raw ingredient,
a miner, a fishermen or a farmer.
There is no way you can trace
it back to a mama farmer
and ensure that the mother got paid.
Typically what happens - if
I am that smallholder farmer
and I sell my coffee, cacao,
barley to the buying center -
is, I might get a paper receipt,
I might not get a paper receipt.
Because it is all cash, I'm
never able to build a history
that allows me to improve my
crop because nobody trusts me.
From the brand's perspective,
if you really want your supply chain
to be traceable and transparent,
you do need to know who the farmer is
and blockchain can do that.
Bitcoin started
as an open source project in 2009.
Blockchain was first used to power Bitcoin
and it's often mentioned in the
context of cryptocurrencies.
There is this proposition
that the technology behind Bitcoin
is gonna take off exponentially.
It's important to keep in mind
that blockchain is not Bitcoin.
Bitcoin is an application
of blockchain technology.
Just like the email is an
application of the internet.
The term blockchain is used to refer
to distributed ledger technology.
Blockchain is a decentralized
digital registry where every participant
in the network holds an exact copy of it.
In the case of the supply chain,
it can keep track of
price or who owns what,
but it can also include information
about weight, geolocation,
and quality among many other details.
Companies using digital
databases can do the same,
but blockchain is more
resistant to tampering
because of the sheer number
of copies of the data.
Every time there's additional input,
a new time-stamped block of
data is created, encrypted,
and linked chronologically in a chain.
A copy of this block is then distributed
to all the devices across the
network and can be accessed
via an app, a QR code,
or even a text message.
The decentralized nature of blockchain
allows companies to reduce
their risks of data loss,
corruption, data fraud.
As essentially there isn't
an intermediary body,
like a government or a
bank or a third party,
that manages this data.
Given that everybody has
the same information,
it creates this general
level of trust amongst them
that the information is true,
it's validated and it's trustworthy.
In the supply chain,
blockchain acts like a digital
twin of a physical product,
most often anchoring to its QR code,
a barcode or an RFID tag,
things that some industries
were already using
to track their assets.
So what happens is when data is tracked
through the sensors and tags,
it's automatically sent to a blockchain.
This adds a level of
operational efficiency
to supply chain operations,
which saves a lot of costs for businesses.
For a while now,
businesses have been trying
to use various digital technologies
to optimize their supply chains,
but blockchain offers an
added level of security.
With standard technologies,
if you digitize a trade document,
you can very easily copy it.
Bill of Lading is actually a document
that shows that you're
the owner of the goods.
So it's a very, very important document
in international trade.
And there have been attempts
to digitize Bills of Lading
for decades now but the
adoption rate remains very low.
There were some massive
fraud scandals in Asia
because an electronic Bill of Lading
was used twice for financing.
With blockchain, you have
the guarantee that there
is, what is called, no double spending.
That this Bill of Lading
cannot be used twice for financing
because it proves the authenticity
of the trade document.
So for all of these reasons,
blockchain has generated a lot of interest
for supply chain management
and international trade.
It's really hard to say whether blockchain
has moved beyond the hype completely.
You know, right now the sort
of stage of the projects
that we're seeing are
mainly at pilot stages.
But what I will say is
that I think blockchain
is being recognized as a really important
technology for supply chains.
Blockchain is being used by
a number of big companies,
big retailers, big shipping companies.
The fashion industry is using blockchain,
especially luxury brands
or really fashion brands
who want to make sure that the products
that are being sold are not counterfeit.
And now I scan, click.
And the magic happens.
Authenticated.
Often when the adoption
of blockchain is led
by a large company, like a
retailer or a distributor,
they have an incentive to
really encourage small suppliers
within their supply chain
to also get on the bandwagon
and adopt blockchain technology as well.
Increasingly blockchain providers
are consortiums and large tech companies
who are integrating blockchain
into their existing tools
for supply chain management,
but there's also a
large number of startups
offering custom solutions.
One of them is BanQu.
It has over two million farmers
and informal waste pickers
across 51 countries registered
on its blockchain platform.
Where we operate, like
Zambia, Uganda, Sudan,
the farmers have a cell
phone that works via SMS,
not a smartphone.
We don't need an internet
connection for the mama farmer.
As long as you have a SIM card
that's connected, which is geolocated,
it's just picking up the location
from farmer to co-op to truck driver,
truck driver to a weighbridge,
weighbridge to the final destination.
One of BanQu's clients,
an international brewer AB InBev,
has just started tracking the barley
that ends up in beer of
their Ecuadorian subsidiary.
Their buying centers
are in remote locations
in the highlands where farmers
like Milta Andrango live.
This area has the highest
poverty levels in the country
and the company hopes
blockchain can change that.
The brewer was already using
devices to measure the weight
and moisture of barley to
determine its quality and price.
BanQu doesn't need any
additional technology,
it just taps into these devices.
The app on the buyer's
smartphone gathers this data
via Bluetooth and only a low
grade internet connection
is needed to send it to the cloud
where it gets added to blockchain.
The smallholder farmer, mama
farmer or father farmer,
when they come to sell their harvest,
they get an SMS message
on their SMS phones
that confirms what was the quality,
what was the quantity
and what was the price.
That digital receipt on their
SMS phone starts building
that transparency.
You're not getting rid of middleman.
You need middlemen.
But you can reduce
corruption dramatically.
BanQu doesn't use
the cryptocurrency feature of blockchain
and it doesn't handle payments.
It just provides farmers
with a secure code
that allows them to cash
out, save money for later
or transfer the sum to their
bank account if they have one.
We primarily work in
the developing countries
because that's where the
biggest disparity is, right?
That's where the biggest abuse is.
That's where the biggest
supply chains are, right?
I mean, you know, Africa
feeds the world, right?
And you know, Asia makes your garments.
At the end of the day,
the smallholder farmer
has never been given
the economic passport.
This economic passport
provides crucial evidence of sales
needed by farmers to open up opportunities
to borrow money at low interest rates.
This can then be used to
expand their business.
If you want to break the cycle of poverty,
just believe and use this information
because that's what
banks normally do, right?
If you needed a loan, you walk
in with your work history,
your light bill and your education,
and that's all we're doing.
Because all the data is on blockchain,
the farmer owns it
and if you don't trust me,
call the CEO of AB InBev
and he has the same
copy of my transaction.
Another widely adopted feature
of blockchain is smart contracts.
It's really a misnomer.
Actually smart contracts are not smart.
There's no AI component to them.
And there are not necessarily
contracts in the legal sense.
They are computer
programs that self-execute
when certain conditions are met.
For example, when a
truck crosses the border,
payment is made
or when the price reaches a certain level,
then an indemnity is being paid.
So the smart contracts
can actually be used
to make any type of transaction.
Using parameters that have been gathered,
smart contracts can also help
to automatically determine
a price, safeguarding
smallholder producers.
This is actually validating
the quality of the crops.
So when you put in a
parameter, the system says,
"Hey, this is out of range" or
"This is in range and
this is the fair price
that you should get."
So you can't game the system.
We can see the origin of
where a product has come from,
but we can also track its chain of custody
throughout the supply chain
and we can see how it's transformed
to become the end product for the consumer
and I think that's really impactful,
not just from a perspective
of understanding costs
and materials
but actually there's the
environmental factors.
Blockchain could help
to track Scope 3 emissions
which are the greenhouse gases produced
along the supply chain.
These account for about 90%
of a company's emissions.
But despite its potential
to increase transparency
and reduce corruption,
exploitation and emissions,
blockchain is not a silver bullet.
From a customer's perspective,
just because we can trace
the provenance on blockchain
doesn't mean we get the full story.
We still know only as much
as the company decides to disclose.
Blockchain is only as
good as the information
that is added to the blockchain.
There's the famous sentence,
garbage in garbage out.
And so having verification
systems outside of the blockchain
to ensure that the data that
is entered onto the blockchain
is of good quality is critical,
but this can be complex.
It can be expensive.
Even though blockchain
is not the only way to prove
the origin or authenticity,
there's increased interest by
brands in using a technology
that can help to build consumer trust,
something that's increasingly important.
A study by IBM showed that over 70%
of people who find
traceability very important
are willing to pay a premium
to companies offering it.
I think blockchain is being
driven mainly by consumers
and consumer demand for transparency.
That's one of the big driving factors
of blockchain right now.
And so unless there's that incentive
to really provide proof that products
within that supply chain
have been ethically sourced,
sustainably produced, then
I don't think companies
are really pushing to use blockchain.
The existing systems that
they have can do the job.
And while this shift in our supply chains
may happen slowly, it could
ultimately be lower costs
rather than increased transparency
that will steer the
industries towards blockchain.
And this could have an impact upstream.
Farmers through this SMS message
now have a different
experience when they're sitting
with a bank, when they're
sitting with the seed company,
because they're not looked at as a number
with a piece of paper that crumbles.
And the best example is, you know,
you see this mama farmer
who all her children are in school today.
They have running water
in their house, right?
All we have done is restored
that mother's ability
to prove her existence.
All we did was make the connection.
She does all the work.
We're just the tool.